el New Start es un tratado de control de
armas firmado en el año 2011 y renovado
en el año 2021 por 5 años más establece
unos límites en cuanto a las ojivas
nucleares que Estados Unidos y Rusia
pueden desplegar y también Respecto a
los misiles para lanzarlas pero ahora
Estados Unidos quiere terminar con ese
acuerdo alegando que Rusia no lo está
cumpliendo porque no está permitiendo
inspecciones en su territorio Estados
Unidos quiere poner fin a este tratado
pero Rusia dice que quiere mantenerlo
aunque sea de manera hipotéticamente
viable como ha dicho el portavoz del que
advierte que en caso de que se acabe
este tratado que es el último tratado
nuclear que se mantiene vigente entre
ambas potencias Estados Unidos habrá
destruido todo el marco legal en el
campo del control de armas